genial nos piden que factor y cm os x
cuadrada menos 49 y el cuadrado y lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta es
que mira aquí tenemos un término elevado
al cuadrado y aquí tenemos otro término
elevado al cuadrado si te das cuenta x
cuadrada tiene raíz cuadrada exacta y 49
y cuadrada también tiene raíz cuadrada
exacta por lo tanto esto me recuerda a
la diferencia de cuadrados siempre que
tengamos algo de este estilo
voy a pensar en una diferencia de
cuadrados algo del estilo a cuadrada
menos b cuadrada entonces lo primero que
voy a hacer es llamarle a este término
que está aquí a cuadrado y ahora le voy
a llamar a este término que tengo a
camps de cuadrada este de aquí va a ser
b cuadrada y bueno una vez que ya tengo
a cuadrada llave cuadrada sería muy
bueno saber cuánto vale a y cuánto vale
b así que déjenme ponerlo por acá a
cuadrado es igual a x cuadrada y bueno
si a cuadrada es igual a que es cuadrada
esto me va a implicar que a vale x
perfecto ya tengo que a vale x y ahora
pues hay que hacer lo mismo para ver yo
sé que b cuadrado vale 49 cuadrada
entonces déjame escribirlo aquí
b cuadrado vale 49 y el cuadrado 49
cuadrada y bueno esto me va a implicar
que me valga la raíz cuadrada de 49 y
cuadrada es decir la raíz cuadrada de 49
que es 7 y la raíz cuadrada de ye
cuadrada que es bien perfecto ya tengo
cuánto vale b también ya continuación lo
que quiero es que le recordemos cómo se
veían las siguientes expresiones que
pasaba cuando yo tenía algo de la forma
lo voy a poner aquí algo de la forma a
más ven que multiplica van aa menos ven
te acuerdas bueno pues esto es la
multiplicación de un mi nombre por un
binomio así que voy a multiplicar
término término a portland me dan a
cuadrada perfecto y después a por menos
b esto me da pues menos a b muy bien y
ahora voy a multiplicar con b b que
multiplica am esto me da pues
pero veas lo mismo que ave entonces a
esto le voy a sumar ave y para finalizar
me queda b que multiplica a menos b b yo
multiplica menos b es lo mismo que menos
b cuadrada y esto lo podemos simplificar
un poco si te das cuenta a b que resta y
ya ve que sumar se pueden ir a b y a
veces se van y me queda simple
esencialmente a cuadrada menos b
cuadrada perfecto que si te das cuenta
está de lujo porque es justo lo que
tenemos aquí arriba tenemos algo de la
forma cuadrada menos b cuadrada por lo
tanto ya podemos ver aquí claramente
cuáles factorización así que lo que
tenemos que hacer es abrir dos
paréntesis uno aquí y el otro acá y
vamos a poner su factorización en
grandote esto va a ser con rojo me
quedaba a es igual a equis que tenemos
que poner aquí
y aquí también tenemos que escribir por
lo tanto voy a poner a que vale x ya que
vale x
y a continuación lo que tenemos que
escribir es ab b nos piden que sea
positiva y tiene el otro paréntesis nos
piden que sea negativa entonces voy a
agarrar el color debe y me va a quedar
más ven pero ve el a7 james entonces voy
a escribir más 7 james y después me
piden que lo ponga en negativo en el
otro paréntesis entonces menos 7 y si te
das cuenta x 7 por x menos 7 es la
factorización de x cuadrada menos 49 y
cuadrada y ya con esto acabamos nuestro
ejercicio